[Music]
and speaking of the Grammys Kelty is
joining us now she's relocated from our
absolute lime-green room with more music
news hey Celts thanks keV absolute is
back as the official spirits partner of
the 60th annual Grammy Awards and we are
so excited to team up with them for all
things Grammys now we were just with
Rita Ora in New York City who recently
collaborated with one of this year's
nominees
ed Sheeran it was all done through an
email and then we met in London did this
song like two hours didn't even feel
like work
she's busy filming the next chapter of
the Fifty Shades of Grey franchise and
is about to release her first album in
five years it's finally been a moment
where I can actually just show off my
musical talent with some of the most
amazing people she's also working on
another very special collaboration with
her fans I'm teaming up with Absolut to
write a song inspired by your amazing
stories of acceptance she's talking
about the open mic project fans can
submit their stories to be a part of the
song that premieres the week of the
Grammys now Reed is opening up on her
own story of acceptance as a young
refugee when I was one we left Kosovo
and we moved to London I had to learn
quickly about the acceptance and the
importance of the acceptance different
there's so many stories of so many
different types of people now that is
some talent right there and of course
we'll have more grammy coverage from our
absolute lime green room leading up to
the 60th annual Grammy Awards this
January
[Music]
you